as is our custom in the leading voices
lecture series the first question to
each speaker comes from the previous
speaker last week we welcome secretary
Paulson's classmate robert rice who had
the following questions on the way to do
the part that I've really been looking
forward to and that is there's one last
question that's the question that you
get to pose to our next speaker and I
looked up who our next speaker would be
now maybe this question is a segue to
your question but our next speaker is
your Dartmouth classmate and former
Treasury secretary Hank Paulson so when
he is sitting in that chair what would
you like him to have to answer I think I
got two related questions for you
number one why in the Wall Street
bailout did you not condition those
funds on Wall Street doing several
things that it needed to do particularly
with regard to mortgage mitigation and
also making money available to Main
Street through small regional banks and
also putting some constraints on
lobbying by Wall Street firms
particularly during the period of time
Congress was trying to reform the
financial system
and secondly Hank after you explain all
of that I would like you to tell us
whether the social benefits of Wall
Street exceed the social costs Thank You
Hank
okay some things in life never change
and those sounded like two questions
rather than one now I'm going to start
with the first one and the second one
and then go to the first one because on
the social benefits vs. costs I have a
difference with Bob I'm a capitalist and
I believe and I believe I believe that
we have a the most prosperous country on
earth which has been for a good while
for a lot of reasons but one of the
reasons is that we have world-class
capital markets so we've had world-class
capital markets and if we want to stay
on top and if we want to remain
competitive we're going to need strong
capital markets now why do we need
strong capital markets jobs and growth
the capital markets funding the
companies that are going to compete in
the global marketplace create jobs
prosperity for Americans why do we need
good capital markets to provide credits
for fake credit for families that needed
buy homes or send their children to
school or automobiles or cars or for
retirement security on the investment
side now I know why Bob asks the
question the way did because our
financial markets and Wall Street failed
us big time in 2007 or 2008 and there's
been a lot of focus on that and
deservedly so
the mistakes poor risk management
business practices flawed business
practices abusive business practices but
you know if we just leave it at that and
only blame the banks who deserve a lot
of blame we'll be right back here again
because there's been much less talk
about the flawed government policies
that created this problem and the you
know we as a country saved to a little
borrow too much we as a nation and as a
people and of course we have that that
is not inherent that derives from
policies that are flawed and encourage
us to do that why did we have a housing
bubble
we just stimulated the living daylights
out of housing through a whole series of
things tax law
Fannie Freddie FHA and so on so we need
to we need to deal with some of those
things we had a flawed regulatory system
it wasn't a matter of not enough
regulation we needed better regulation
but we had a system that was broke just
plain broke we someone put it in place
after the Great Depression and so we had
emergency powers to deal with with banks
but no emergency authorities to deal
with non banks so we need to learn our
lesson and the lesson to take away is
not that capital markets are not
worthwhile and don't provide social
benefit the lesson we need to take away
from all of this is what mistakes were
made so we can correct them and that's
one of the things we do in the United
States of America when there's a problem
we shine a light on it then we move
quickly to correct it and we need to do
that now in terms of his first question
on the tarp this is what something I've
heard a lot and let me be really clear
what we were doing the purpose of the
tarp bank capital program in October
when we announced that program and on a
single day we put capital in nine big
banks with over 50% of the deposits and
then in the days and weeks after that we
recapitalize many many banks these were
non failing banks most of them were
healthy banks and so the idea here was
rather than nationalizing banks as they
failed and putting all kinds of
restrictions on them was to get ahead
inject confidence prevent a collapse
recapitalize the the banking system you
could only do that if it was a voluntary
program so we needed to design a program
that was going to be that was going to
protect the government the government
will get paid back and the banks would
voluntarily accept now let me just
really quickly put that in context for
you in early September we had been
forced to in order to prevent a real
calamity come in and essentially
nationalize Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
they had five point four trillion
dollars and securities outstanding
it would have been an incredible
disaster if we had to do that we did
that we've fired the CEOs we wiped out
the equity shareholders this was a tough
action the following weekend we had
Lehman Merrill Lynch and AIG going down
all at the same time we tried very hard
we couldn't find powers that worked to
save Lehman they just weren't any we
tried Merrill Lynch avoided failure
because they are acquired by B of a if D
of a had acquired Lehman it would have
been worse because Merrill would have
gone down and that would they were
bigger and it would have been a worse
situation AIG was taken over very tough
to herim CEO was replaced it was
essentially nationalized we then had to
have Treasury guaranteed three point
eight trillion dollars of money markets
to avoid an implosion when we're up
working to get tarp wamu and essentially
failed and was acquired by JP Morgan who
markovia was fired it was acquired while
it was failing then after we had tarp
six European nations have come in and
had to nationalize certain banks so we
made a judgment we had to do something
very dramatic and move quickly and we
were tired I'm dealing sequentially with
one failing institution after another
and dealing with it on an ad-hoc basis
so we said how do we do something it
doesn't look like nationalization
doesn't have a taint - it doesn't have
government control let's design this
security non-voting preferreds and I had
hoped and expected we would get two to
three thousand banks to accept but no
sooner that we announced it then critics
like you know the people that asked the
question and others it immediately
started pounding and saying you know
what you can't let banks get away with
this you got to put restrictions you got
to make them lend they do you got to
make them lend more we said more than
what you know more than you know at the
top of the bubble more than they would
have went if they failed you know how
are we supposed to make them lend you
got to make them lend you got to put
this restriction you got to put that
restriction and as soon as that happened
the banks started to get concerned
and then Congress passed legislation to
retro actively change the rules so we
had many banks and applied had been
approved and withdrew many others didn't
apply
so rather than heavy two or three
thousand banks take capital we had
roughly 700 it worked
the minoo the but they also rushed to
pay back the government now I look at it
and say if three thousand banks have
taken capital and kept it for three to
five years that would have been more
useful than any stimulus plan but it's
interesting to me always that the same
people that stigmatized the program and
criticized it and and and and said you
got to make the banks do this we're the
ones that caused the banks to pull back
and regional banks not to take money are
the ones that now say hey why didn't you
give money to the regional banks okay
why did more banks take it why didn't
they lend more so that's that's a
perspective you can see I care a lot
about it but the one thing I've got to
say I was in a class and I tried to
explain it the class didn't really
understand and when I left government I
thought the tarp was one of the most
successful government programs of all
time I thought that but a polls showed
92% of the American people were against
the tarp and 60% were against torture so
so what do I know and I and I think the
reason is is we don't like bailouts or
rescues in our country in the United
States of America when we believe that
if people take risk they can make money
but if they take risk and then the
taxpayers got to boil bail them out and
then they're gonna pay bonuses that's
wrong I think it's wrong everybody
thinks that's wrong I did things that
were abhorrent to me but I did it for
the American people because can you
imagine but you saw what happened when
Lehman would tell what would happen if
we did one of these big institutions go
down but I was never able to make that
connection between Wall Street and Main
Street
and so even though Bob asked two related
questions there really one in the same
because you if you don't understand the
role of markets and and how important
they are to Main Street you're never
going to understand why we had to do
what we did so on that note and you can
tell I don't care at all about this
right yeah I'm sure let me tell you I
was a bob was a better student than I
was you know we were and he was also a
great public speaker even in college and
he was a tremendous actor he was he was
he was a star in all the plays shout is
there working now do you have in case we
needed it but it says it's got a green
light up okay good all right it's up and
running I want to thank President Kim
for putting this program together these
programs together I think they've been
great and I especially want to take a
moment of personal privilege here
because it's a great honor for me to
have a chance to moderate this program
with secretary Paulson I was played a
small part in the effort to try to
address the financial problems of 2000
2008 and we were on the brink of a
disaster of extraordinary proportions as
a nation and as a world and really one
person stood between this country and a
fiscal meltdown of catastrophic
proportions which would have impacted
Main Street in an incredibly dramatic
way and that person basically thought
outside the box and did things which
weren't typical of governance and got
the Congress to do things which I never
expected the Congress to be willing to
do and led the world
in a process of at least stabilizing and
then trying to correct what were some
fundamental failures of our financial
markets and as a result we avoided a
massive disruption which would have
affected every American in an incredibly
difficult way unemployment clearly would
have gone well beyond what it's gone we
would have had probably an event equal
to the depression in my opinion and that
one person who stood up and basically
did what needed to be done was Hank
Paulson
and was probably something he learned
here at Dartmouth to cause them to do a
sure first off obviously we appear to be
facing another significant financial
issue Europe is in a difficult situation
our own countries just gone through a
touch of turmoil over the debt ceiling I
guess I would ask you do you see
similarities between what we're going
through right now and 2008 and do you
see Greece as being a precursor much
like Lehman was to the possibility of a
very significant devastating fiscal
event yeah that's a question I think a
lot of people are asking right now I see
them as being very very different
situations today let's take the u.s. in
2008 what's our issue our issue is
growth we need growth we need jobs in
the and this is an issue for the whole
economy in 2008 the housing bubble fell
disproportionately on the banking system
and a bubble by definition means that
it's unrecognized until it bursts and
there's no doubt the full extent people
saw the bubble but the full extent of
the housing bubble was a surprise to the
markets in 2008 it really was and so
today the risks are I think pretty
obvious and I think people largely
understand them and are focused on them
and I think the the banking system is
got more capital and has been regulated
and a banking system is stronger in this
country much stronger in the financial
markets in this country are much
stronger the challenge is growth and let
me just tell you why the challenge is
growth the consumers in and so much debt
in 2007 debt was a hundred and fifty
percent of disposable income in 2007 if
you can imagine that
today we're still delivering it's a 110
percent of disposable income and in
terms of wealth that's I'm sure it's got
to be off the charts it's by looking at
that in terms of disposable income it's
still way above any historical level so
it's unrealistic to think that the
growth is going to be led by consumers
anytime soon until that adjusts itself
so that's a challenge so now let's look
at Europe the effects of the housing
bubble of 2008 taking longer to play out
in in the capital markets and in the
banking system I guess the way we say
the banking system in Europe now and by
far the most pressing problem and the
important problem and challenge in the
global marketplace today our structural
issues in the European Union and here
I'm talking about the large fiscal
deficits in a number of nations there
and structural issues in the EU itself
now the leaders are working on this and
it's going to take some time to resolve
these problems and they've made some
progress today taking a number of steps
and they haven't been easy to take given
the technical issues and the political
resistance and so on they've got a lot
more to do and there's gonna it's going
to be messy politically because they're
going to be tough political issues but
one thing you shouldn't underestimate is
the will power and that in the
commitment of European leaders to
preserving the European Union to hold it
together and to preserve stability now
in terms of Lehman versus Greece I see
that is very different than most
respects Lehman was an institution we
worked to save we didn't have the
authorities to save it we didn't have
emergency powers for it for the non
banks on the other hand the EU has been
working and taking steps and has got the
powers for for four months to deal with
with the sovereigns like Greece out of
the 2008 banking crisis and financial
crisis leaders everywhere are have
requirements for banks to have more
capital and I'm a big believer we need
that there's going to be a spotlight on
European banks and I think the one
similarity is it's going to be important
for those largest most important
European what the banks that own the
most sovereign debt to be well
capitalized thanks you what what what
about this S&P downgrade and what do we
need to do to get our fiscal house in
order in your opinion here in the United
States okay two questions first of all
the SP downgrade the first of all our
political process our government hasn't
been working in a triple-a level so
there's no doubt about that but despite
that I would take US Treasuries over
other sovereign debt the other triple a
sovereign debt any day of the weekend
clearly would that's not to say we don't
have important issues we have to deal
with in this country but in my judgment
other major countries have all have more
significant more difficult to manage
economic issues than the United States
of America now you know you asking me
that question of course senator Gregg
was the you know just a key member of
the bowles-simpson Commission and
there's no doubt that by far the biggest
issue the biggest structural issue in
the United States is our fiscal deficit
it's a formidable issue but coming back
to the bowles-simpson deficit Commission
what they showed I think to the world is
what I think a lot of the markets
already understood is that we are such a
rich country and such a big economy that
if we act soon and their shared
sacrifice we can solve this problem by
spraying the sacrifices throughout
different segments of the of our country
so no group
sacrifice too much now the longer we
wait
obviously the more difficult it's going
to be so what do we have to do to get
our fiscal house in order I think it
comes down to we need growth and so we
need growth and so when we go about we
have the reform entitlements and we have
to reform a tax system and we have to
reform a tax of some sort will give us
the revenues we need and give us growth
and so I start off by saying despite all
the criticism and how poorly the
government performed and all of that and
I think the criticism is deserve it let
me tell you something we've had
beginning with with bowles-simpson and
then throughout the summer this is the
best public debate I've seen on this in
my lifetime and people understand more
about the problem and they've ever
understood before and that's number one
number two I would say as important as
cutting it and cutting expenses and
that's essential that alone won't get
you there
you've got a reform you need reform you
got to reform entitlements and when you
talk about entitlements think Medicare
that's where the huge dollars are that
for the episode and you need a reform
the tax system so all this stuff I find
it very uninteresting and not even
terribly relevant about should the Bush
tax cuts expire what should we do with
rates the system the question that
should be asked is since we need more
revenues how do we get them in a way in
which we have as little drag on jobs and
growth as possible how can we get them
and remain competitive and no one who's
credible that I've heard defends our tax
system I don't think our tax system will
get us there so we need reform and we
need basic reform I'm hoping you know
Judd Gregg was the one I think this idea
of the super committee was the first
person I ever heard of from was you so I
think the
idea is as judge and the way I look at
it is this
we of course Congress took an
underwhelming step in terms of the first
cut but it was a step right
okay it was a step and now we've got the
supercommittee and we can hope they
undertake reform hi for one think it's
unlikely we're going to get it reform
until we have a new election but I can
hope but even if we don't get it reform
you know if they get their objective one
and a half trillion dollars which is an
easy left on a forty trillion dollar
base over five years you can say X in
ten years excuse me you know I can't
make it worse than it really is I mean I
thank you for catching me Jay but over
ten years it's it's an easy lift but let
me tell you you've got to start
someplace
and hopefully that will build some
momentum and but you can't get reform
unless you that can only be done on a
bipartisan basis and that can only be
done with both parties want to
compromise and cooperate and I don't
think we can do that where the players
we've got in Washington I think we need
a little new election but I hope I'm
wrong and even if I'm right I think
we're headed in the right direction well
that's that leads to another question
which is that we obviously went through
this very significant although in my
opinion a rather artificial event this
summer so I'd like to get your thoughts
on the Tea Party and its influence on
the process and also on the possibility
of a threat of default to our debt Wow
okay well let's start with the Tea Party
even before that I want to say something
about political process and it's sort of
crazy for me to speak about it with
senator Gregg because he knows more
about it than I do
but a political process one of the
lessons I learned in Washington is it's
almost impossible to get something big
and difficult and controversial down
without a crisis twice
we got Congress to act and they did it
before the system collapsed but it took
crisis and even if the vast majority of
members of Congress in my judgment
understood the deficit and we're
determined to do something about it it
would still be an ugly process to get
there and it would it would take time to
be an ugly process now get to the Tea
Party I have all my Republican friends
and Democrat friends and everybody
mainly Democrats asking about the Tea
Party and and trying to put me on the
spot or get me to defend if I start off
by saying you know what the Tea Party
didn't come onto Capitol Hill with guns
and take over by force they were elected
election elections have consequences and
voters and both parties respond to the
people who voted for them and there are
a lot of people that came in the last
election that the voters wanted them to
come in and change government and I'm
hoping that the next election the voters
will say you know what we want you to
come in and compromise and solve
problems and fix the the major problems
and fix what's wrong we want you to do
that maybe I'm being naive but I would
like to see a fiscal deficit be the
centerpiece of a campaign and then the
whoever wins feels motivated to come in
and solve these problems but the
electorate's got to be be educated
because right now you know what voters
are telling people in Washington we want
benefits that we don't want to pay for
you know we want benefits we don't want
to pay for and how selfish is that
because you know all of you who were
students here
your parents want what I want for my
kids I want them to have the same
opportunity I have and I'd make great
sacrifices for them to have that
opportunity but in our country we've got
my generation being incredibly selfish
not willing to make a sacrifice and the
people that we'll pay for is the next
generation but anyway I think we need a
now on the debt ceiling when I say to
people on that and I've said all the way
along whenever I got asked what I said
is there's no danger of default leaders
on both sides said repeatedly that they
were gonna raise the debt ceiling so it
was an ugly process to get there it
wasn't pleasant but again I come back to
what I said earlier that to get major
reform you're gonna have to get people
that are going to want to cooperate
compromise and I think we're going to
need another election to get us there
but at least I never thought we are in
danger of default and at least the
American people now have had a real
education I want to change focus and
then we get questions from everybody in
the audience but you've been one of the
leading experts and one of the most
knowledgeable people in the country on
the issue of China you've set up a new
Institute on China tell us what you
think China's going is it a threat to us
either economically or militarily and
what's their future and what are their
problems in your opinion and tell us a
little bit about this Institute oh it
should be at darkness by the way okay I
wish it were if I if I lived in New
Hampshire be a Dartmouth Riley but I
live in Chicago Dartmouth I should have
started off by saying they're my
proudest moment was when I gave a
commencement address in 2007 I you know
I I love the school I think you're
getting as good an education as there is
it's sure improved you know I was in a
class today and sophomores were asking
me all kinds of sophisticated question I
didn't know what an investment banker
was when I was there I was an English
major I didn't know they difference
between a stock and a bond and you know
so it's now the Institute what we've set
up at the University of Chicago it's an
independent Institute that's affiliated
with Chicago and it's going to be
focused on US China and the reason it is
is I believe when you look at major
problems in the world today I don't care
if they're in the economic arena I care
a lot about environmental issues and
I've always been interested in that
Alysha area or in in foreign policy
national security if you look at these
big issues if the US and China aren't
cooperating and working together we've
got almost no chance of solving them and
if we are working along with others
we've got a good chance so I view this
relationship is very important and this
is not going to be like other
Institute's it's not going to be a
think-tank it's going to be a do tank
we're going to we're going to try to get
things done I've got people that are
action oriented and we're going to focus
on the first event we're going to do is
going to be unsustainable urbanization
and we're going to we're going to look
to negotiate and and get important
things done now China that question John
that's the first question you asked was
is China a threat and I get asked that
all the time are they are they somehow
we're going to knock us off our perch
are they a threat to our position
globally our economic leadership our
global leadership let me begin by saying
is saying this very very simply we are
by far the largest economy the richest
economy in the world there is not
another major economy we've got
significant issues but all of them
including China have much more daunting
issues than we have our ability our
problems that are of our own making
they're not of China's making and our
ability to solve them is going to be
more difficult if China has problems so
those people that are rooting for China
are rooting for the wrong thing be
careful what you wish for because if
they have problems our problems will be
the more significant number one number
two if you look ahead people say where
are we going to be 10 15 20 30 50 years
ago from now I would never ever bet
against the United States of America but
if we are not
they're continuing to be the world
leader and the most powerful and
important country on earth it won't be
because of China or any other nation
it'll be because we didn't have the
wisdom and foresight and we didn't have
the political leadership to make the
policy adjustments we need to make to
stay in competitive and stay on top in
terms of strength and I'll get to the
military in a minute
but in terms of strength that our
strength including our military strength
is rooted in our economic strength China
understands that everyone understands
that so the most important thing we can
do is fix our economy and that's number
one now I get asked
there was a story I saw the Wall Street
Journal today there is a picture of a
Chinese aircraft carrier I think and I
get asked the military question and when
I say there I can't speak from
experience but when I say in China and
in the US that there are a fair number
of people in the US that are concerned
about China's military involvement and
the motives behind it there are a good
number of people in the region in the
Asia region that are kind of concerned
of that and I believe the key thing we
need is trust and you only get trust or
transparency so I'm a big believer of
military-to-military dialogues
transparency trust building the
militaries and when you look at the
economic relationships between our two
countries
we have a lot of economic tension but
that's the nature of economic
relationships you know 30 years ago we
didn't have any economic relationship we
didn't have any intention now the good
news was no tension the bad news was we
didn't have a relate relationship we had
tension with the Japanese or Canadians
or Europeans so but we have a lot of
people that are used to working with the
Chinese in the economic Channel so when
their problems we know how to deal with
them the military we don't have the
history the militaries don't like or
trust each other as much
we really need that that trust building
there and I think that's that's really
important and then I end with strength
you know I'm all for coming with the
position of strength that needs fixing
our economic problems in being strong in
Asia being strong economically in Asia
the trade agreements big strong
diplomatically and be strong militarily
in Asia now thank you okay thanks now
we're going to take some questions from
the audience who has the first question
okay there's some questions back there I
thanks for taking my question
there are several Western countries that
are suffering from the same disease
which is high debt and very high
unemployment and the discussion so far
has been mostly about how do we control
that and unfortunately according to many
has been cutting spending which is
leading to apparently too high
unemployment and is low in GDP I haven't
heard a single politician president or
prime minister lay out a plan on how to
create jobs and boost GDP which in the
end creates prosperity and M pays down
the death are you aware of any plan
anywhere in any country and most
importantly what would you do to create
jobs and you know using job creation and
prosperity to pay down the debt okay I'm
just not going to comment on politicians
I'm always trying to stay out of that
but I would say for myself these are
because I think this is about job growth
economic growth job creation and this is
a as you say it's a problem in many
parts of the developed the world and I
think even in the developing world you
know China has got a really difficult
job to keep doing this because nowhere
in the history of the world was any
nation transformed itself so
dramatically so quickly in the demand
for change is is is unrelenting and the
Chinese people have got high
expectations so that leadership in it I
think it's going to be increasingly
challenging for them to you know be as
integrated as they are under global
economy and to continue to do things and
as well as they've been doing if they
don't speed up the pace of reform and so
so I think it's a challenge everywhere
but they get to your specific question I
don't think that there are I don't
believe in silver bullets I think we
need fundamental reform so the question
is really our political system and can
our political system adapt and so the
kinds of reforms we need I had talked
about taxes a little bit so we clearly
need if we had a tax system that
incentivized savings and capital
accumulation and let us raise revenues
in a way in which we could still be
competitive and raise the revenues we
need they'll make a big difference and
there's a couple ways we can go but it
takes tax reform so tax reform I think
trade is very important I believe in
trade and I think it's disgusting that
we haven't had you know WTO agreement
but that we haven't even passed our free
trade agreements we have up before
Congress with allies like Colombia where
everyone knows that would add jobs and
growth and so Colombia Korea and so on
so getting trade agreements immigration
my gosh and the immigration and the the
idea that we've got all these bright
people from all over the world to come
the United States and rather than the
stapling of a visa you know a green card
to their diploma we send them back we
least send them back we send job
creators and innovators out of this
country how stupid is that
the energy policy you know I that we
could we could talk about what we need
to an energy policy and then I have got
one and I I think they have to wait
awhile to figure out how to fund this
but when you look at unemployment and
you look at unemployment among males 20
to 50 and you look at the danger of
young people being out of work you can
afford anything when you're young other
than not to work and not to grow and so
dealing with that and I just think we
need to think out of the box we need to
say maybe you know this is a great
country maybe there should be universal
service for everybody not just in the
military but Peace Corps Habitat for
Humanity whatever so everyone gets
training and then maybe some kind of
equivalent to a GI Bill where we get the
skills training and the training we need
in this world so there's a lot of things
that need to be done but I think the
reason it's hard for politicians to talk
about them is because they they're not
that difficult conceptually but as jut
and I were talking they're just not easy
issues in Washington if they're
analytically easy like Social Security
they're politically difficult some like
Medicare and literally difficult and
politically difficult but there's not
low-hanging fruit because it's hard for
democracies to do the fundamental reform
we need but there are things that can be
done they create jobs and growth but
we're gonna have to be competitive to do
that thank you there's some students we
had a question down here there's a
student question then we'll go back up
and I didn't even get to education which
is just huge idea
secretary Paulson in early 2008 when
you're brokering the deal between Bear
Stearns and JPMorgan you famously asked
JPMorgan to decrease the price they'd
pay from $4 the $2 a share in the name
moral hazard so my question is why did
you think that the shareholders should
take responsibility and take the
punishment from moral hazard and not the
managers well let me say the managers so
let's just talk about moral hazard I
really believe in moral hazard because
no matter how how good regulation is
it's unrealistic to think regulators
will uncover the problems that the banks
didn't uncover themselves unless you
thought the banks are intentionally
trying to blow themselves up and so what
you need is you need every customer
every lender to the banks every
shareholder every every borrower to be
focusing on that Bank
okay so we're all hazard so I believe in
that but we didn't have emergency
authorities for to deal with Bear
Stearns it was either bankruptcy or
being taken over now if you don't think
management lost their job let me tell
you they're not running you know
management was gone etc there was no-one
at Bear Stearns that thought there was a
bailout but when I looked at it I was
conscious of the fact that that the Fed
the United States of America was
assisting that transaction so we got a
call on Thursday night that said you
know what we're gonna fail there's going
to be bankruptcy if the government
doesn't come in now there's something
wrong with a picture that says the
government's going to come in if there's
more room then I thought that there's
more if there's more room then the
government should provide less incentive
okay why should the government be paying
more so that the shareholders would get
something and so I felt that now but
later
the deal couldn't get done it wasn't
going to get done without raising the
price and you know a number of others
said to me you're right let's not let
let that get in the way so this wasn't
that I was a mean-spirited or I wanted
people that you know that the have their
equity wiped out it was the same thing
the the AIG was structured in a way in
which were Fannie and Freddie
we had criticism that we wiped out the
equity shareholders and Fannie and
Freddie at the time and the preferreds
when we structured the deal but the
government was there and the government
was was taking big losses and big risk
and can you imagine if and people call
that a bailout
could you imagine they almost shot me
anyway but they would have done if we if
we had taxpayers come in to pay for the
shareholders and in those companies
management went at Bear Stearns as part
of the takeover you had management top
CEOs one at AIG if they went in Fannie
and Freddie it wasn't we didn't have all
the tools we needed so that was good
questions over here oral hazard within
the firm so you've talked a lot about
regulation of firms themselves but as
somebody who ran Goldman it seems that
henceforth were always going to have a
situation where traders and managers in
the firm are doing extremely convoluted
complex things and nobody at the top can
fully understand what they're doing with
the firm's money and therefore since
those people are paid on commission it's
kind of heads I win tails the firm loses
so within the firm how can we do a
better job of managing that risk that's
a really good question that's a huge
issue and people focused on compensation
and on the amount because some of the
amounts are obscene but it's really even
more important as a system and this is
something we focused on and I focused on
very hard at goldman sachs first of all
people that pay traders formulaic
compensation and give them a percentage
of the training profits you know
I would say get what they deserve but
they didn't deserve what the taxpayers
got it too so but what happens is you
then have it if it's traitors get a
percentage of the gain on the on the up
side and don't pay for their losses that
doesn't work you shouldn't have
formulated compensation number one so
the form in which you get a compensation
and we were very careful with that and
we gave a big part of the conversation
and equity that had to be held and then
the the other big protection you have in
these firms is having experienced people
on the trading desk who were
shareholders and and and and really had
every incentive to look out for the firm
overall and then the last thing which I
think many firms ignored was they would
think of the control side in operations
as being the back office and look at
cutting costs and what you need to do is
put really experienced capable people
former traders former bankers in the
control side you've got to pay them the
same way you've got to have great people
and if there's a debt if there's an
argument between them and the traders or
the front office they've got a win so
you these institutions are not easy to
run and risk management is very very
important over here sir I think we
started the century with a fairly
balanced balance sheet for this country
I didn't go to Dartmouth so I'm a little
slow but I don't understand why we
haven't had a war tax why aren't we
asked to pay for those two wars rather
than out of our debt but going basis a
lot of people ask that question and when
I come back with is the the the the the
the answer I gave before we clearly in
my judgment need more revenues if you
look at revenues if you look over a
40-year period they've been roughly I
don't know 18 John what 18 point to a
tube GDP something like that and
expenditures are what 21 22 % point ages
yeah yeah okay and so now revenues are
about 15 right and and expenditures are
what 24 22 and a half okay so so
expenditures are hot so we need we need
more revenues and the but we have a tax
system that is really broken
okay just really really broken it is
filled with loopholes which is just a
one form of social spending or another
you know you know look at you know you
know something is sacrosanct like the
mortgage you know the mortgage deduction
I don't happen to have a big mortgage
but if I if I had a million dollar
mortgage why should I be able to deduct
that and a rent or not cut something I
mean whose and and so there's there's
huge loopholes on the corporate side we
have a system that really doesn't let us
in my judgment be competitive in terms
of the way we tax corporations it's just
an through weighted we're on a step for
the rest of the world and again it's
filled with loopholes different
industries pay different amounts there's
all kinds of crazy incentives and we
have a situation where almost half the
people in this country don't pay federal
income taxes okay they pay other income
taxes but it's just a it's a system
where we we need a fix yes taxes are
very very important and I tend to not
focus on should there be a war tax what
do they do with the rate because I look
at that it's just moving this is a bad
analogy because we're not the Titanic
but it's like moving the deck chairs
around okay
what we need is fundamental reform and
we need a tax system that does credit
and lets us get the revenues and let
think it will get the revenues in an
equitable way and that we're gonna be
competitive and I'm repeating myself
sorry yeah down here with the students
if we could take one of their questions
again do you have to sit in the front
row as a student to get a question
parallel secretary Paulson I have a
question for you about another one of
your passions which seems being the
environment and given what seems to be
that in the minutes they've been divided
very much on a partisan basis what can
we do to raise awareness about
environmental issues and what role can
the federal government play in trying to
create awareness and eventually resolve
the issue well I
to me this is hugely important and a big
I just tell you what I'm doing my
interest personally had always been in
wild beautiful places you know
biodiversity working to help create the
first national parks in China and Yunnan
Province or in Chile or do it doing
things in the US or working on the Great
Bear Rainforest and that's what I'm
that's what's fun for me because I like
to be I when I was here I'd like to go
to Hubbard walk or you know or places
like that but I'm very concerned very
very concerned about global warming I'm
very concerned about all the issues with
energy efficiency alternative sources of
energy so the Paulson Institute at the
University of Chicago when we engage
with China one of the major issues is
going to be environmental because we're
the two biggest economies were the two
biggest emitters of carbon were the two
biggest importers of oil we've got
common interests
and my view is the only way we solve
this problem is developing and deploying
new alternative sources of energy and
then are cost effective in doing that in
scale and governments aren't going to do
that governments can create the policies
that help do that but we and there's
there's a lot of things that need to be
done there and China right now is well
ahead of us in terms of what they're
doing you know they're but they but they
need to do it they are they've got a
you've got a huge issue
they've got 1.2 billion Chinese and
we've give them a very bad model here
you know 1.2 billion Chinese can't live
the way we live in the in the US there
are not enough resources in the world
you know you have another two or three
hundred million people in the middle
class it won't work
we need and they realize you need new
models of growth in the new models of
energy efficiency so there's a lot this
that's going on in China and so when my
first the things I do there will be on
sustainable urbanization it's not
because I like to be in cities trust me
I'd rather be in Hanover than in New
York but when you look at where the
problem is and when you look at the
issues around water which are another
just a huge huge issue and you look at
at energy use and and this is so I want
to get some things done we're gonna need
to have major breakthroughs and so and
if it doesn't get done in countries like
China and India it's not going to get
done and so when I think the kinds of
things I pushed on are these you know I
often and talk with people in India
China other developing nations and they
say you guys polluted when you went
through your development phase and I
simply sure did but there are two things
that are different right now now we got
the science to know how bad it is and
now we got technologies that we didn't
have them and so it is very wrong
not be using the cleanest commercially
available technologies so I think it's
morally wrong and economically wrong to
have tariffs on environmental goods and
services to have clean technologies that
aren't being used because there's
tariffs so there's a whole series of
things like that that that I that I push
on but I think these these issues are
very important issues I happen to be an
optimist because I believe that the
experts are often wrong in terms of
technology development I love to tell
the story that years ago I was working I
forgot what it was with with Motorola
and they had a consultant do a study as
to how big the market was for mobile
telephones and they came back and said
900,000 because the mobile felt phones
are about this big the battery lasted
about 15 minutes it cost like two two
dollars a minute and they didn't see the
the huge you know upside through
technology and I really do think we need
to develop clean technologies sorry you
got me going on something there we've
got time for about two more questions
actually we're out of time take a couple
more questions right so let's go up here
to a question and then we'll come back
to students for last question first of
all thank you both so much for sharing
with us this afternoon we'll all go home
wiser and hopefully less worried my
question secretary Paulson is you spoke
about the United States must be strong
economically and militarily in China
could you expand on that a little bit
more and say how you think we should be
stronger how do we get stronger well I
think a little bit was almost the way I
answered the last question it certainly
is not spending more money on military
okay we spend multiples of what other
countries spend on the military and even
there there's room to cut and still be
strong we just have to spend in the
right put ways in the right places and
it's very hard to cut military spending
because because part of this is jobs and
in politics and everything else so
the but the what I think we need to do
is we need fundamental reform because I
do believe that the Chinese and their
everyone understand economic strength
and I think that Bob Rice's question
about Wall Street it was actually I mean
a joke but it was a very good one
because you know that there was a time
when people looked at us and looked at
us as having the pixie dust our capital
markets were the envy of the world they
wanted to look like us and we've lost
that my my Chinese counterpart Wang Shi
Xiong when I talked to him about opening
up their capital markets because I
believe they needed to open up their
markets for their good and they weren't
gonna be able to do make the kinds of
changes they needed to make in China
unless they reformed an allocated
capital and had investment products for
their company for their consumers so
they were ripped off putting deposits in
the banks and getting less than
inflation and so on so but when I was
making that case to him he said listen
you used to be my teacher my teacher
doesn't look so smart anymore given
what's happened in your capital markets
so I think for us our strength is going
to be I do believe that our economic our
strength our global preeminence is
rooted in our economic power and all the
other things America represents and I
think all that is still here we just
need policies and Chinese are no
different than anyone else they
understand strength okay and right now
they look stronger than they are I have
great admiration for what they're
accomplishing we don't look as strong as
we are and we've got great underlying
strength we just need some strong
leadership and some policy reforms
they're going to put our Connie back on
the right footing and that's going to
take a while
I'm down here too a student for the last
question a little bit over time but
those domination sorry sorry thank you
very much for coming and talking today
sorry to hammer on on the China issue
but um I think I recall goldman sachs
itself or maybe another American company
predicting that the China economy the
Chinese economy would overtake the
United States like around 2025 or
something and I'm just wondering how do
you think we can compete in the long run
and just like a basic level that if
Chinese worker like reaches like you
know half the productivity of an
American worker since they have four
times the population that like they
would still double the overall economic
output in the United States let me come
back to so-called experts when people
just draw lines and assume that this
trend is going to continue and we're
three times bigger than the Chinese
economy there's a lot baked into this
first of all in terms of of China's got
significant challenges you know
significant challenges not the least of
which is continuing to manage an economy
where the pace of change is just so
relentless and used this mixture of
administrative measures and market
reforms no economy just goes like this
and under an outlaws gravity forever
okay they're their issues in every
economy and so I hope China continues to
do well because it's going to be a big
benefit to us but let's talk about what
their issues are enormous environmental
challenges a the the idea there's huge
issues in terms of big wealth gaps and
inequities and they're working very hard
to deal with that so they're
dramatically increasing wages wages are
going up very quickly as they need to
increase domestic consumption because
they realize they're too big there to be
dependent on exports and be dependent on
US and others on exports so wages went
up 20% last year but to manage that
they can't continue to grow unless they
develop new energy models and new models
for growth they've got so they've got
they could change it one of the other
issues they've got is they're in the
middle of a you know the it's the
political and so to understand China
recognize that the last leadership
change you know almost 10 years ago when
zhang jie men went to - who was the
first time that a sitting Chinese leader
dim Vic is a successor so the party
apparatus did that and and and this is a
second time and so there are all kinds
of doing and froing and and they look
through the lens of domestic stability
so every decision they make in China
whether its economic or whether it's
personal liberties whether it's you know
all these things is going to be what
gives us the most immense tech stability
now I happen to believe that what will
give them the most domestic stability is
speeding up the pace of reform and
speeding up if some of the personal
freedoms and liberties and that's the
case we we need to make but they've got
they've got meaningful challenges and
all I've got to say is don't bet against
the United States of America for that to
happen you have to sing to China you
know you could grow that China line for
forever pretty soon they'd all be living
like we are in the US and there wouldn't
be enough resources in the world and
it's just it's impossible so they can't
keep growing like that forever they need
to change their growth curve and we need
to get our job done but let me come back
to what I said the question China is an
interesting foil this is too much about
China the question about where we're
going to be come back to what I said to
judge it's not going to be determined by
China trust me it's not going to be
determined by any other country it's
gonna be determined by us okay the
decisions we make the policies we would
in place that's going to be America
and if China has problems and I hope
they don't and I'm not predicting them
soon if they do our challenge will be
greater because because we're integrated
into a global economy thank you thank
you very much mr. secretary
we
that's a pretty good place to stop don't
bet against America I think that's you
now have to ask Jeff Immelt end of GE
because he's the next guest in this
seriously so I'll begin with I must say
Jeff fortunately I'm asking you the
question not Bob rush yeah and because I
can only imagine what he would ask but
but my question is a simple one today
we've talked about that our big need in
this country is economic growth and jobs
and Jeff you're serving right now as
chairman brock obama's president obama's
jobs council and so my question to you
is what we need to do what can be done
in the short term to create jobs in this
country and more importantly in the
longer term what do we need to do to
regain our competitiveness maintain
regain our competitors and create jobs
in the United States of America and you
all want to come back to get the answer
that
you